i want to go back to december 1991 and
paint for my audience the fact that when
blood sugar sex magic came out it was an
amazing time in music when you think
about it and to put it into
some kind of perspective
you guys were on the road with pearl jam
as the opening act nirvana was in the
middle
and you guys were the closers that is an
amazing moment in music i can't imagine
what that tour must have been like
you guys
had an album that was really breaking
big pearl jam was coming out with 10
and nirvana we know what what happened
with them what was that tour like back
then i remember just feeling like you
know they're good bands but nirvana
that they were really carrying a heavy
magic with them like just this feeling
like they
are a powerful entity to be respected
when we were playing together in
you know 88 89
like when we were still playing in clubs
it really felt like a life-or-death
thing that we we had to succeed at what
we were doing you know like like not
just commercially but like our shows had
to have an energy our shows had to move
people people had to be dancing you know
like our styles were in large part
developed because we were under that we
put ourselves under that pressure of
wanting to be good oh that's good you
know who was good
nirvana they sure were when we played
with them yeah they were just good no
i mean that was a
life changer what do you mean anthony
what do you mean they were just good
like they
what was it you know i feel like some of
this is a natural thing like john has a
very clear understanding of dynamics and
then for me the that feeling that john
is so beautifully describing it was just
natural the first time that we ever
played it was just natural to
have an energy to have a passion and
have a live or die
aesthetic to everything that we did
but i feel like nirvana had that
naturally as well like they were
certainly good at their instruments and
songwriting and chemistry and all that
but then they also just had a
combustibility that
that came with birth or came from god or
came from the planets or something did
you get to hang out with kurt cobain and
talk about being a front man i would
imagine you
being around
other front men so to speak uh would be
important
i mean i i was usually pretty nervous
when i whenever i was hanging around
with him um
just because i was in awe and
and he wasn't the type who wanted to
discuss being a front man he was just
kind of shy and in his energetic
state
but uh flea and i had some some nice
moments with him at a some mtv show
where we snuck away and went backstage
and just sat with him while he was
getting ready to play
and that was a nice experience um what
was unusual about it that uh that he was
sitting and playing and kind of loose as
a goose and like loose he was loose and
and warm and inviting and relaxed and it
wasn't like he had been on tour for a
long time and was all you know
emotionally chaotic he was quite within
himself and said yeah come and sit and
yeah um
he was a beautiful dude and he left us
with a ton of
unbelievable music and energy